just happened news right here 5,000
points 02 we haven't been here since
March the 10th 2000 it has been almost
15 years since we last saw Nasdaq 5,000
steps here is the difference marks the
10th 2000 felt a lot better than it
feels right now if you take yourself
back to those times people were feeling
it getting paid loving these markets
high-fiving it confident across the
board so let's go to scarlett foo in the
newsroom scar break this down for us
5,000 that's huge it's huge and yeah
things feel a lot different than last
time around as you mentioned we're about
a week shy of the 15 year anniversary
that the Nasdaq set its record high of
50 48 of course we're so 48 points away
from that after breaching 5,000 for the
first time since march of two thousand
but there you see the chart over the
last fifteen years the big slide down
and it was very quick and the long slog
back up what's interesting here is how
the nasdaq has outperformed the SP and
dow so far this year with gains of about
five and a half percent which is more
than double what we've seen in the Dow
and the S&P during the same time I was
looking at some of the other big
constituents and the nasdaq composite
and if you look at the numbers they're
staggering Apple for instance so far
this year up almost eighteen percent
it's got a market cap of 757 billion
dollars the biggest company in the world
amazon also another big constituent with
a market cap of 178 billion dollars of
twenty four percent in the period and
starbucks also around back in two
thousand up fifteen percent this is
again so far this year with a 71 billion
dollar market cap if you look at how the
nasdaq has done how these some of these
big companies have done since the low in
october of 2002 which was the low for
the nasdaq after it had breached that
5,000 level this is also staggering to
Stefan eric 13 thousand percent increase
for Apple since that october two
thousand too low amazon twenty one
hundred percent starbucks up seven
hundred eighty percent the reason we
don't even include a company like Google
in theirs because Google was not a
company at that time it wasn't even
around back in two thousand now if you
look at the top
waiting's back in two thousand verses
now it's notable here Microsoft was the
number one weighted stock in the nasdaq
composite back then followed by Cisco
and Intel these are all old tech
companies if you look at what it is
today Microsoft still up there but
overshadowed certainly by Apple and
Google of course making its entrance as
well because it was not around back in
two thousand one final note I just
wanted to make here was that it took a
lot longer this time to get from 4,000
to 5,000 we checked and we just have to
finalize the numbers here but at first
glance it would appear it took 461
actual days or 313 trading days to get
from 4,000 to 5,000 this time around
last time in 1999 to 2000 it took 71
actual days at 49 trading days so that
was a very very rapid rise up whereas
this time it seems orderly in comparison